bonsoir david alors qu'est ce qu'il faut
retenir de ce point presse olivier
ferrand et bien écoutez olivier dans un
premier temps en ce point presse
hebdomadaire sur le court on avait
russie théâtre est attendu au lit et
veyran dévoilé un arsenal de mesures
sanitaires pour tenter d'endiguer cette
deuxième vague et qui s'apparentent plus
violente que la première selon les
scientifiques et selon les mots du
ministre de la santé après son coup de
gueule à l'assemblée nationale il ya
deux jours olivier ferrand a donc
détaillé ces nouvelles dispositions à
sanitaire des programmes et elle les
soins non urgents sollicité aller
renforce son personnel soignant douze
mille professionnels de santé se sont
déjà portés volontaires pour prêter main
forte dans les ehpad et hôpitaux
français à mettre en oeuvre des
évacuations sanitaires pour les
territoires elle est plus en tension
dans contre 61 déjà et mobiliser
ensemble du système de soins pour
limiter l'impact de l'épidémie sur les
réanimations la capacité de rami nation
de réanimation justement en france un
autre sujet abordé le ministre de la
santé n'a pas hésité à balayer à l'idée
que s'il y avait plus de lits de
réanimation il n'y aurait pas de nouveau
confinement
écoutez la réanimation c'est tout sauf
un acte anodin
ce n'est pas une situation banale c'est
pas un mauvais moment à passer
la réanimation quand on y entre on n'est
pas sûr de pouvoir en sortir dans
certains cas on ne décède dans d'autres
cas heureusement on y décèdent pas mais
on peut ressortir extrêmement fatigué
avec des séquelles des séquelles
respiratoires de séquelles
cardiovasculaires musculo squelettiques
neurologiques et parfois cognitive je ne
dis pas ça pour faire peur je dis ça
parce que c'est la réalité est qu'on ne
peut pas parler de réanimation avec
légèreté comme s'il s'agissait seulement
de capacité d'accueil est de l'île leur
confinement révérend a eu des propos
très clairs également il a mises en
garde les fronts
et a souligné l'importance de respecter
ce nouveau confinement sens à la
deuxième vague serait plus haute et plus
longue que la première il a par ailleurs
confirmé la fermeture des commerces et
points de vente à emporter à 22 heures à
paris comme l'avait affirmé ce matin
anne hidalgo
le confinement est une mesure qui est
difficile qui en portent beaucoup de
contraintes dans notre quotidien et que
ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure plus nous
le respectons moins longtemps ça durera
et plus ce sera efficace donc toutes les
petites hésitations que les uns et les
autres peuvent avoir au quotidien
peut-être aller voir les copains ça fait
longtemps qu'on n'a pas pris l'apéro
finalement j'ai pas j'ai quasiment pas
bougé cette semaine où bon allez on peut
manger à 15 dans la salle
pas grave on ouvrira les fenêtres tout
c'est tout ce genre de situations qui
peuvent se poser à nous qui sont
foncièrement humaine et bien elles
prolongent la durée du confinement elle
réduit son impact
le ministre de la santé on appelle une
nouvelle fois à l'union nationale la
france reste ce jeudi est le pays
d'europe qui compte le plus grand nombre
de cas de kobe de 19
la situation sanitaire est alarmante et
olivier ferrand a voulu avant tout
responsabiliser les français face à ce
nouveau confinement
merci beaucoup david pour toutes ces
précisions d'avis de khalifa en direct
du ministère de la santé